hello and welcome to the chicky science
show so
a lot of things have changed in the past
year new rules
lockdowns social distancing they have
changed their lives to different extents
in different ways
but one change you may not have thought
about is your microbiome
yes you heard me right the human
microbiome that includes all the
bacteria
fungi and viruses residing on or within
your tissues
notably your skin lungs and oral cavity
and what i'll focus mainly on in this
video
your guts microbiome now the microbiome
is known to be dynamic
it changes as you age depends on your
sex your geographical location
and your diet so you might be thinking
well sure my microbiome has probably
changed since a year ago
but this video is more than to point out
the obvious
you see the microbiome are not just
passengers within our bodies
but they play a variety of functions
they aid in our digestion
they aid absorption of nutrients they
shape our immune response
and synthesize their own bioactive
compounds such as
short-chain fatty acids so they're not
just passengers they play critical roles
in metabolism immunity and neural
development
amongst other emerging functions and so
maybe unsurprisingly the gulp microbiome
and dysbiosis
of the gut microbiome has been
associated with a variety of diseases
such as obesity type 2 diabetes
alzheimer's
cancer autoimmune diseases and
depression and so if we think about the
current pandemic
having a good immune response makes you
less susceptible to severe consequences
of sales costume infection
moreover studies seem to be suggesting
that obesity
and type 2 diabetes may put you at a
greater risk of developing more severe
symptoms of kf19 infection
now with the help of this recent
perspective article and some other
articles as well
for the remainder of this video we will
address three key points
firstly how the pandemic interventions
might be altering our microbiome
and decreasing its diversity leading on
to secondly
why should you care about this and is
the pandemic just accelerating or
helping us to
further highlight the decline that's
already being seen in microbial
diversity
throughout the past few decades and how
both the young and the old may be most
vulnerable to these changes
and then thirdly to stop me getting too
negative we'll end on a positive note
talking about what can we and what can
you do about this
and what should we do about this is it
even a problem so firstly then how have
the pandemic interventions
potentially disrupted our microbiome
well disrupted may not quite be the
correct words
since the implications of the pandemic
are going to vary from person to person
but overall whether or not there's been
enhancements or losses in microbiota
can be summarized nicely in this
perspectives figure and so to break it
down we'll falsely look at ways in which
you can gain microbiata
and how the pandemic interventions may
be disrupting this
so there are many different
environmental factors that can foster
microbial diversity
and so this includes mobility and the
ability to travel
being out in the environment being in
close proximity to others including the
wider community and your own family and
pets as well as diets being very
critical which we'll come back to a bit
later
and as well you'll notice that it also
says mother and
infancy is a critical moment when your
microbiome is initially established
and we'll come back to that a little bit
later as well and so given that these
are the ways in which you can enrich
your microbiome
it becomes apparent that the preventions
in place to
prevent the spread of k19 could be
having impacts on your microbiome
diversity
firstly hygiene is of critical
importance to prevent the spread of
kevin 19.
and i'll probably reinforce this point
at the end but i'm not trying to say
that we shouldn't be following these
measures
these measures have been put in place
for a purpose and that is to prevent the
spread of kv19
in fact i'll come to the point at the
end that the aim should be to both
follow these measures and prevent cover
transmission
but also to be able to reduce any
potential negative impacts that these
prevention measures may be having such
as microbiome alterations
anyway back to my point in this pandemic
we have made radical changes and
hygienic measures
this has included the deployment of
personal protective equipment
notably the wearing of face masks the
frequent handwashing and
application of hand sanitizer as you
enter different shops
and workplaces in addition to continuous
cleaning of bleach in public places
and with disinfectants and homes and so
as i says cleaning is essential to
prevent the spread of this
virus but these measures may also be
affecting
general microbiome transmission and to
quote from this perspective article
implementing much stricter hygienic
practices now to contain cavite 19
transmission is necessary
but increased hygiene may come at a
microbial cost by decreasing microbial
acquisition and re-inoculation following
loss
although that cost is not yet known and
these aren't the only measures
the second way that transmission has
also been prevented has been through all
of the social interaction
that have been disrupted from the
closing of schools to workplaces
from social distancing and the formation
of social bubbles these could all
potentially be having negative
consequences for microbial transmission
and so there are many reasons why you
should care about your gut microbiome
firstly the fact that dysbiosis of the
gut microbiome
has been associated with a variety of
diseases as i mentioned earlier
including obesity and type 2 diabetes
which could put you at more risk of
developing severe symptoms in response
to kf19
but a more general reason why you should
be interested or potentially concerned
about the slauson microbial diversity
comes down to the so-called hygiene
hypothesis first proposed in 1989 by
david stratton
now as by the name hypothesis it is
still yet to be
fully proven but it comes down to the
fact that even despite the current
pandemic
there has been a general decline in
microbial diversity
and associated with this decline in
microbial diversity
has been an increase in immune
hypersensitivities
such as asthma and other allergies and
so back in 1899
stratton proposed the hygiene hypothesis
after observing
that hay fever was less common among
children with older siblings
suggesting that those children had
increased exposure to microbes in early
childhood
due to inevitable unhygienic contact
with older siblings
and so although the evidence is a bit
sparse at the moment
a recent demographic analysis of covert
19 associated
mortality rates in 122 countries
have suggested that inadequate
sanitation and exposure to microbial
diversity
may be associated with reduced covert 19
associated mortality
and so in the study they noted an in
first correlation between
covid19 associated death rates and water
quality scores
and so the authors of the study proposed
that microbially stimulated
innately enhanced levels of type 1
interferon
may be protective against cover 19
mortality in these populations
and so to go back to an earlier point
the gut microbiome seems to be playing a
major role in training
the immune system and so for these
reasons the impacts of hygiene and these
pandemic interventions
may be having a bigger toll on the
microbiomes of the young and the old
so starting with the young birth and
early infancy
are critical periods for microbiome
establishment and development
and so the microbiome of newborns are
initially colonized by maternal microbes
acquired during vaginal delivery and
through skin to skin contact
along with support for the microbiome
from from prebiotic foods
and microbes provided in breast milk and
in line with the hygiene hypothesis
it's been shown that being born by
cesarean section for instance
appears to increase the risk of later
allergy asthma and obesity rates
and so it's likely that the microbiome
could be at play in this association
and another key acquisition of
microbiome for young children
is through contact with others at school
which obviously as well as being
implicated by the current
prevention measures and so whilst the
microbiome has been
turned to blossom through infancy and
reach full maturity
by adulthood by later life the
microbiome diversity is known to
decrease
and many chronic diseases associated
with aging have some link to the
microbiome
and so covered 19 has dramatically
affected the care mobility and social
interactions of elder populations
moreover elderly may have greater
anxiety and fear for their own health
during this pandemic
whilst trying to keep with with the
absence of social support and physical
and emotional connection
for their own and others health and so
i've mentioned a number of possible
problems
that could be resulting from these
pandemic interventions
but is it all bad news well some
evidence seems to be suggesting that
some of the interventions
may be beneficial to improving our
microbiome diversity
for example the closure of restaurants
has resulted in an increase in home
cooking
along with the conscientiousness of
making better food choices in terms of
trying to boost
your immune system for example a small
study was conducted in spain
the so-called spanish cava diet study
and what they found was that cavite 19
confinement in spain
has led to the adoption of healthier
dietary habits and behaviors
in the studied population as reflected
by a higher
adherence to the mediterranean diet
however this is just a small study and
the impact of the pandemic
on our individual changes in food
consumption timing
quantity quality and frequency may
profoundly be impacting
our gut microbiome composition and
function in a variety of different ways
for example more generally the pandemic
has disrupted food supply chains
and may be putting more vulnerable
populations more at risk by facing food
insecurity
from the economic effects of the
pandemic response but there are things
that we can do about this
firstly diet heavily influences the
microbiome and that's something that can
be easily changed
for example increasing the consumption
of probiotic foods
foods that contain living strains of
bacteria this includes fermented food
products such as kefir
kombucha miso kimchi and even saudi
bread which i do believe became a bit of
a popular craze
in the uk lockdown and the most widely
investigated fermented food is kefir
with evidence from at least one
randomized control trial suggesting
beneficial effects in both
lactose malabsorption and helicobacter
pylori eradication
nonetheless i feel like there still
hasn't been enough investigation
into the potential of these different
probiotic foods in terms of improving
the composition and function of the
microbiome
alternatives to probiotic foods are
prebiotic foods
foods or chemicals that are important
for the growth and proliferation of the
microbiome
and most famous of this is increasing
dietary fiber
and so in terms of the current pandemic
it's very important to ensure the
provision of healthy food assistance to
low-income families and children
moreover other interventions should be
made to boost prevent the spread of
cavit 19 but also to aid healthy
microbial diversity
this includes measures such as keeping
open urban parks but ensuring the
maintenance of physical distancing
spending more time outdoors avoiding
unnecessary antibiotic use
and encouraging physical contact with
those among co-quarantine family members
and pets
and so these are kind of immediate
actions that can be taken
but if we think more about the bigger
issue at hand and the declining
diversity
in the microbiome which i mean in all
honesty we still don't really know what
the implications of this will be
or if it is really a problem but in the
case that it is
we should start thinking about ways that
we can act upon this and so a lot of
work is being done in terms of looking
at microbiota transplants
which would be i guess an alternative to
the taking of probiotics to try and
increase the microbial diversity for
example of the guts microbiome
alternative interventional strategies
include the development of drugs that
can target modify or mimic the gut's
microbiome activity
for example one company that i know is
researching this area is pure tech
which is asking the questions what if
weaker treats immune and infectious
diseases by mimicking the ways in which
the gut microbiota maintains a healthy
immune system in humans
so this is just a taste of the huge
amount of research that is still being
conducted and will continue to be
conducted into the gut microbiome
which i find incredibly fascinating
given that we
are not alone in our bodies and we share
our lives with our gut microbiome
wines our aura microbiome and skin and
lung
microbiome you know we've got to embrace
it but we've got to look after it as
well
and so as i said at the start this is a
perspective of a perspective
and there's still much we don't know
about the microbiome and the
implications of the pandemic
and so i lastly just want to reinforce
my point that we should be aiming to
both prevent code for transmission
and to reduce the negative impacts of
pandemic control
and i think that there are ways that we
can achieve this so without i want to
give a
thank you to my patreon supporters and i
hope you've learned something in this
video
and thanks for listening